Wounded in similar ways, wounded in similar ways. It sounds like something that a hippie would say, but the truth is we're wounded in similar ways. Hi, I'm here with Amy Pickett-Williams, and she's going to talk about her nonprofit that works with grief. She's a psychotherapist with a long extensive history of working with a lot of issues, but especially grief and loss. And, you know, usually try and start the Taproot Therapy Collective podcast with kind of a silly joke or something. Doesn't feel appropriate here on a grief-centric episode.
以相似的方式受伤，以相似的方式受伤。这听起来像是嬉皮士会说的话，但事实是我们确实以相似的方式受伤。你好，我是Amy Pickett-Williams，她将谈谈她致力于悲伤辅导的非营利组织。她是一位心理治疗师，在处理许多问题方面拥有长期且丰富的经验，尤其是悲伤和丧亲之痛。你知道，我通常会尝试用一个傻笑话或类似的东西来开启“根源治疗集体”（Taproot Therapy Collective）播客。但在这一期以悲伤为中心的节目中，这似乎不太合适。
So I think we'll just kind of go into it and I'll let you talk about some of your work and you know, I'll chime in as needed if needed. That sounds wonderful. That sounds wonderful. I'm excited to share and thank you so much for having me on your podcast. It looks like you guys do a lot to really touch the world. So it's an honor. Thank you so much. It looks like based on your information, there's a lot of overlap. So I'm curious to see where that Venn diagram, you know, kind of begins and ends. And I'm always interested in, you know, new perspectives on on old issues. Yeah, absolutely. So if you'd like, I'll just dive in a little bit about my professional experience and then how our nonprofit got started and some of the science behind why we have our nonprofit and the tools. Does that sound good? Yeah, that's great. All right. So I've been
所以我认为我们还是直接进入主题吧，我会让你谈谈你的一些工作，你知道，如果有需要的话，我会适时插话。听起来太棒了。听起来太棒了。我很高兴能分享，也非常感谢你邀请我参加你的播客。看起来你们做了很多真正触动世界的事情。所以这是一种荣幸。非常感谢。根据你的信息，看起来有很多重叠之处。所以我很好奇那个维恩图（Venn diagram）在什么地方开始，又在什么地方结束。我总是对旧问题的新视角感兴趣。是的，绝对是。所以如果你愿意的话，我会先简单介绍一下我的专业经验，然后介绍我们的非营利组织是如何开始的，以及我们非营利组织背后的科学依据和工具。听起来不错吗？是的，那太好了。好的。所以我已经
a grief therapist for over 25 years, and my heart song is actually working with families who have experienced the death of a child. But in the years of doing this work, it's morphed into working with all types of loss, including a family member or close friend, a pet, and then reaching further. And a lot of times people don't think about grief and loss in regards to the loss of a relationship or loss of self-identity with transitions and fertility, loss of finance, homelessness, and even globally, that sense of loss of safety and sense of peace with what's going on inside our world in regards to terrorism and war and global warming. I mean, all of those different areas can trigger a lot of experiences and feelings of loss. And so when we have these feelings and these
做了超过25年的悲伤治疗师，我真正热爱的工作是与经历过丧子之痛的家庭合作。但在从事这项工作的这些年里，它已经演变成处理各种类型的丧失，包括家庭成员或亲密朋友的离世、宠物的离世，然后进一步延伸。很多时候，人们不会想到关于关系丧失、因转变和生育问题导致的自我认同丧失、经济损失、无家可归，甚至在全球范围内，考虑到恐怖主义、战争和全球变暖，人们对安全感和内心平静感的丧失。我的意思是，所有这些不同的领域都可能引发许多丧失的经历和感受。所以当我们有这些感受和这些
emotions, I think what we found over the years is people aren't knowing how to work with them in order to grow with them. I think it's really important, a caveat, and I've said this for years as a grief therapist, is we don't heal from grief, but we can grow from grief. The scar is always there, but ultimately the hope is our tree or our plant or our cactus will grow around that scar and be able to, as we integrate, in order to find purpose and meaning. If we learn to find purpose and meaning in our loss, we can hopefully work to obviously changing our own selves, but in the more altruistic side, be able to change our world. And so that's part of why our nonprofit was formed. And I'm happy to go into the personal story about that in just a minute.
情绪时，我想我们多年来发现的是，人们不知道如何处理它们以便从中成长。我认为有一个重要的警告，作为一名悲伤治疗师，我已经说了多年了，那就是我们不会从悲伤中“痊愈”，但我们可以从悲伤中“成长”。伤疤永远在那里，但最终的希望是我们的树、我们的植物或我们的仙人掌能够围绕着那道伤疤生长，并能够在我们整合的过程中找到目标和意义。如果我们学会从丧失中找到目标和意义，我们就有希望不仅改变我们自己，而且在更利他的一面，能够改变我们的世界。这就是我们成立非营利组织的部分原因。我很乐意在一分钟内详细讲述背后的个人故事。
But the nonprofit itself has four goals. It's to remind people they're not alone in their grief. So much of the time when we experience loss, we feel like we're the only one and no one can understand us. And while that is true to a point, everyone has their own story. The emotions behind loss are universal. And our second goal is to teach these somatic-based tools, that mind-body connection. For some, it's that mind-body, spirit, or soul connection that can lead to integration and finding purpose and meaning. Our third goal is to connect with other resources that support people in grief,
但该非营利组织本身有四个目标。首先是提醒人们，他们在悲伤中并不孤单。当我们经历丧失时，很多时候我们觉得只有自己一个人，没有人能理解我们。虽然在某种程度上这是事实，每个人都有自己的故事，但丧失背后的情绪是普遍的。我们的第二个目标是教授这些基于躯体的工具，即身心连接。对一些人来说，这是身、心、灵或灵魂的连接，可以引导整合并找到目标和意义。我们的第三个目标是与支持悲伤人群的其他资源建立联系，
like you, like your podcast. And the fourth one is to stand in solidarity for all people and all types of grief. And I'd love to share a little bit with that fourth goal, how this all came to be, because it's very connected to that fourth goal. I'd love to kind of engage you on two of the points you brought up, because I think that would be a good invitation. And for people who may feel like they don't work with grief, or they don't understand it, or that this isn't relevant to them. I mean, the first one is, like, you said that this is something that you don't, grief is some, you said in so many words that grief is something where it's not, what I see is a lot of cognitive kind of avoidant counseling be like, you know, like, oh, you're sad, and then you get happy,
比如你，比如你的播客。第四个目标是为所有人以及所有类型的悲伤声援。我很乐意分享一点关于第四个目标的想法，这一切是如何形成的，因为它与第四个目标紧密相连。我很乐意就你提出的两点与你互动，因为我认为这将是一个很好的邀请。对于那些可能觉得他们不处理悲伤，或者他们不理解悲伤，或者认为这与他们无关的人来说。我的意思是，第一点是，就像你说的那样，悲伤是……你用很多话说了悲伤是……我看到的是很多认知上的回避式咨询，就像，“哦，你很伤心，然后你变得快乐了，”
or I had this bad thing happen, and I was sad, and now I got better. And it's like, what grief work is doing is dealing with something that is unhealable and irrevocable that you learn to grow around, you know? And I think without that perspective, it's hard to really do the work. And then the second point that you mentioned is that like that is a process of like everything, global warming, politics. You know, I saw people coming in with 20 in in 2016 that didn't lose a child, but they were still experiencing grief
或者“我发生了这件坏事，我很伤心，现在我好转了。”而悲伤辅导所做的是处理一些不可治愈且不可撤销的事情，你学会围绕它成长，你知道吗？我认为如果没有这种视角，就很难真正开展工作。然后你提到的第二点是，这就像是一个过程，关于一切，全球变暖，政治。你知道，我看到人们在2016年进来，他们没有失去孩子，但他们仍然在经历悲伤，
because the way they thought things worked was not how they were working or something like that. And I think that when people tell me they don't work with grief, it's like, no, you just don't see it. Because I work with this as an identity disorder a lot, and I have a lot of people that say, well, I don't work with people where there's lots of different parts of them and it's like everybody has lots of different parts you may not have amnesia between them but you're ignoring the parts you know like you're letting
因为他们认为事情运作的方式并不是它们实际运作的方式，或者类似的事情。我认为当人们告诉我他们不处理悲伤时，就像是，不，你只是没看到它。因为我经常把这当作一种身份障碍来处理，我有很多客户说，好吧，我不和那些有很多不同人格部分的人一起工作，而事实是每个人都有很多不同的部分，你可能在它们之间没有失忆，但你在忽略这些部分，你知道，就像你在让
them fight with you you're engaging with the trickster and teenager and you know the mother wound and you're not separating them or you know whatever and to me it's like i i haven't um so many people who come in you're saying like, you don't want this to be real. You don't want to accept this. You're deflecting off of it. You're pretending your emotions are powerful over it. But it's just it just is what it is. You just don't want the world to work this way.
它们与你争斗，你在与骗子（trickster）和青少年部分互动，你知道，还有母亲创伤，你没有把它们分开，或者你知道无论是什么。对我来说，就像我……很多人进来时，你说，你不希望这是真的。你不想接受这个。你在回避它。你在假装你的情绪对它有强大的控制力。但它就是它本来的样子。你只是不希望世界以这种方式运作。
It feels like it's not fair. It's not right. You can't survive if this is the case. And that's underneath almost every issue, you know, in therapy. I mean, I'm not comparing every issue to something like the death of a child or the death of a loved one, but we accept, grieve, and process things that way. You know, the language of the stages of grief is relevant to how we deflect about our ADHD not wanting to do taxes, you know, like, I don't know, could you speak to that? Or is that something that you see? Oh, absolutely. I mean, losses around us all the time. And,
感觉这不公平。这不对。如果情况如此，你无法生存。这几乎是治疗中每个问题的核心，你知道。我的意思是，我并不是把每个问题都比作丧子之痛或失去亲人的痛苦，但我们以那种方式接受、悲伤和处理事情。你知道，悲伤阶段的语言与我们如何回避我们的多动症（ADHD）不想报税是相关的，你知道，比如，我不知道，你能谈谈这个吗？或者这是你看到的情况吗？哦，绝对。我的意思是，丧失时刻围绕着我们。而且，
you know, it can be, you know, in the trauma world, people talk about big T, little t. And obviously, in grief, we can have little lesser losses, right? And sometimes grief, there is a important caveat, actually, a little speak to that relates to what you're saying though, is that not all grief has trauma, but all trauma has grief. So it depends on obviously our autonomic nervous system and how we're impacted by that experience. So every day we experience losses, right? Maybe we were working really hard on a proposal for our job and our boss said, sorry, this isn't going to work, right? That's a mini loss.
你知道，在创伤领域，人们谈论大T和小t（Big T, little t）。显然，在悲伤中，我们会有较小的丧失，对吧？有时悲伤，实际上有一个重要的警告，我想谈谈与你所说相关的内容，那就是并非所有的悲伤都有创伤，但所有的创伤都有悲伤。所以这显然取决于我们的自主神经系统以及我们如何受到那种经历的影响。所以我们每天都在经历丧失，对吧？也许我们正在为我们的工作提案努力工作，而我们的老板说，抱歉，这行不通，对吧？那是一个微小的丧失。
But the part in part with loss is that loss triggers loss triggers loss. And so while I maybe worked on a proposal for, you know, a big, I'm not a marketing person, but let's pretend like I am. And that my boss says, no, this isn't going to work for us. That may trigger those feelings of loss when our parents said in our childhood, you know, you're not doing this right. And you did this wrong. Right. And so it's important to know that it's, it can be accumulating. And if we don't know how to work with it, it's just going to build more and more in our bodies, which can lead to physical issues and can lead to chronic
但丧失的一部分是，丧失会触发丧失，丧失会触发丧失。所以虽然我可能为一个……我不是市场营销人员，但让我们假装我是。我为一个大项目努力工作，而我的老板说，不，这对我们来说行不通。这可能会触发那些童年时期父母说“你做得不对”和“你做错了”时的丧失感。对吧。所以重要的是要知道，它是可以累积的。如果我们不知道如何处理它，它就会在我们的身体里越积越多，这可能导致身体问题，并可能导致慢性
illness and chronic stress. And so we have to be aware that, yes, we experience loss every day. And then how do we work with that? And the way I believe we work with it from a somatic perspective is looking at that window of tolerance. You know, Dr. Dan Siegel came up with that, and then Stephen Porges really broadened it with polyvagal theory. And one piece that I always share with my clients is if we are experiencing this loss accumulatively every day, and we're seeing it on the news, part of what we need to do is learn how to get back in our window, right? And I think of a window as that space of calm. Dr. Porges talks about ventral vagal. We could call it just our calming place. From a yoga perspective, it's called sakta. There's many different ways to look at that window.
疾病和慢性压力。所以我们必须意识到，是的，我们每天都在经历丧失。然后我们如何处理它呢？我认为我们从躯体角度处理它的方式是观察那个“容纳之窗”（window of tolerance）。你知道，Dan Siegel博士提出了这个概念，然后Stephen Porges通过多迷走神经理论真正拓宽了它。我总是与客户分享的一点是，如果我们每天都在累积地经历这种丧失，并且我们在新闻中看到它，我们需要做的一部分就是学习如何回到我们的窗口内，对吧？我把窗口想象成那个平静的空间。Porges博士谈到了腹侧迷走神经。我们可以称之为我们的平静之地。从瑜伽的角度来看，它被称为“Sakta”。看待那个窗口有很多不同的方式。
And so one of the ways is we have to learn these tools on how to get back into our window so that we can cope and work every day. But the other piece that's just as important is how do we grow our window so that when we experience these losses after loss after loss, we don't go outside of it to that place of like intense anxiety or anger, or to the opposite, the bottom side, the part below the window where we're just immobile and we just can't function. And so one of the ways these somatic exercises can work is growing our window from like the size of say an attic window, which I'll see in my therapy office all the time to maybe a sliding glass door
所以其中一种方式是，我们必须学习这些工具，如何回到我们的窗口内，以便我们能够应对并每天工作。但同样重要的另一部分是，我们如何扩大我们的窗口，以便当我们经历这些丧失之后又丧失时，我们不会跑到窗口外面去，跑到那种强烈的焦虑或愤怒的地方，或者跑到相反的一面，即窗口下方的部分，在那里我们只是瘫痪了，无法运作。所以这些躯体练习可以发挥作用的一种方式是，将我们的窗口从比如阁楼窗户的大小（我在我的治疗室里经常看到这种情况）扩大到滑动玻璃门
window. So we can ride these waves when we experience loss. Yeah. And I think somatic experiencing has that idea of the window of tolerance. Is that similar? Yeah, that's a big piece of it. And any of the somatic theories really include that piece. And that's thanks to several different people. But Dr. Siegel and Dr. Porges are two big ones.
窗户的大小。这样当我们经历丧失时，我们就能驾驭这些波浪。是的。我认为躯体体验（Somatic Experiencing）有那个容纳之窗的想法。这类似吗？是的，那是其中的重要部分。任何躯体理论确实都包含了这一部分。这要归功于几位不同的人。但Siegel博士和Porges博士是两位重要人物。
Yeah, absolutely.eter levine all of those big guys yeah can you and gals yeah pat ogden too um can you say anything about um kind of your early observations of putting these series together because i mean my experience with the psychotherapists that are like really driven that go on to connect with the whatever, you know, however they want to conceptualize, you know, this kind of their depth modality and somatic and experiential stuff is like, they already kind of knew it earlier in their career, they just didn't have the language, they didn't know the history of the profession, which isn't taught a lot of the time. And you know, you worked, you said with pediatric and oncology. I mean, did you start to kind of see early, like this is, was there any kind of seed of what you do now in that, you know, when you were putting that together? 100%. I mean, at the time I didn't know, like early in my
是的，绝对是。Peter Levine，所有那些大人物，是的。你能谈谈你早期将这些系列整合在一起的观察吗？因为我的意思是，我与那些非常有动力、继续与他们想要概念化的任何东西（你知道，无论他们如何概念化这种深度模态、躯体和体验式的东西）联系起来的心理治疗师的经验是，他们职业生涯早期就有点知道了，只是没有语言，他们不知道职业的历史，这在很多时候并没有被教授。而且你知道，你说你曾与儿科和肿瘤科合作。我的意思是，当你把这些整合在一起时，你是否开始在早期看到某种你现在所做事情的种子？百分之百。我的意思是，当时我不知道，比如在我的
training, I was not taught somatics in my work. I mean, most of us in grad school, especially, maybe not now, but you know, I finished in the late 90s. And it's not evidence. Yes, you have to do CVC. It's the gold standard. Yeah, okay, good to know. Well, I mean, and so we were taught like talk therapy, right? And in reality, I was finding that, you know, sitting with someone and holding space is very, very important. And I and I believe in that 100%. But I think what I was finding in my work with children that were dying and their family members after the death was holding space only went so far, right? You can tell your story, but then how do you work with
培训早期，我的工作中没有被教授躯体疗法。我的意思是，我们大多数人在研究生院，尤其是，也许现在不是，但你知道，我在90年代末完成学业。这不是证据。是的，你必须做CVC。这是黄金标准。是的，很高兴知道。好吧，我的意思是，我们被教导的是谈话疗法，对吧？实际上，我发现，你知道，与某人坐在一起并保持空间（holding space）是非常非常重要的。我百分之百相信这一点。但我认为我在与垂死的儿童及其家人在死后的工作中发现的是，保持空间只能起到一定作用，对吧？你可以讲述你的故事，但接下来你如何处理
what is now inside your body? And the science then came from that, right? In the mid 90s, we started recognizing it, but it really started about 10, 15 years ago, really recognizing that why we need to work with our body and that we do hold the space in our body. And if you think about it midline, we have the chakras from a yoga perspective, we have the endocrine system, and we have the vagus nerve. So whether you're looking at it from an Eastern or Western side, all of this is reconnected with our body. And from the vagus nerve perspective is, you know, it's the 10th cranial nerve and it's a bi-directional highway, but it really mostly goes body to brain over 80%. And so if we're just talking, we're not working
现在在你身体里的东西？科学随后就从那里产生了，对吧？在90年代中期，我们开始认识到它，但它真正开始于大约10、15年前，真正认识到为什么我们需要与我们的身体合作，以及我们确实把空间保持在我们的身体里。如果你考虑一下中线，从瑜伽的角度来看，我们有脉轮，我们有内分泌系统，我们有迷走神经。所以无论你是从东方还是西方的角度来看，所有这些都与我们的身体重新连接。从迷走神经的角度来看，你知道，它是第10对脑神经，它是一条双向高速公路，但它确实大部分是从身体到大脑，超过80%。所以如果我们只是在交谈，我们并没有在处理
with what we're holding in our body with loss. And so early on in my career, well, I didn't know about the vagus nerve back then. I knew that when I would just do some breathing with a patient or their family, and I would just take a moment. And even if they were just mirroring what I was doing with that longer exhale, I would notice a little bit of calm. That's not to say that they weren't in such extreme agony, right? But they were able to take that moment in between those tsunami waves, which leads me to that tsunami wave. I do want to speak to this. This is really important in the grief world. Dr. Jill Bolt Taylor is the one that really recognized this. She was, I believe, a neuropsychologist or neurologist. And I learned this tool many, many years ago that I taught with clients, but I didn't know who came up with it.
我们因丧失而保持在身体里的东西。所以在我职业生涯的早期，好吧，那时我不知道迷走神经。我知道，当我只是和病人或他们的家人做一些呼吸练习，并且我只是花点时间。即使他们只是在模仿我用那种更长的呼气所做的事情，我也会注意到一点平静。这并不是说他们没有处于极度的痛苦中，对吧？但他们能够在那些海啸般的波浪之间获得片刻的喘息，这让我联想到了海啸波。我确实想谈谈这个。这在悲伤世界中非常重要。Jill Bolt Taylor博士是真正认识到这一点的人。我相信她是一位神经心理学家或神经学家。我很多年前就学到了这个工具，我教给客户，但我不知道是谁想出来的。
So I had to do some research. But the way our brain works when we experience an intense, intense emotions of grief, our brains allow us to feel that feeling for about 90 seconds, and then it dissipates. That's not to say that another tsunami wave isn't going to come back up, but it's probably been the number one thing that way early in my career, I learned this. And it might've, it was probably before her, even people came up with it, but that our brain will only allow that intensity for a short amount of time. So it's in between those tsunami waves of the ocean, that reprieve that we're able to work with our grief. And even Victor Frankel spoke about that in his incredible quote about the stimulus and response. It's in between
所以我不得不做一些研究。但当我们经历强烈的悲伤情绪时，我们大脑运作的方式是，它允许我们感受那种感觉大约90秒，然后它就会消散。这并不是说另一波海啸不会再涌上来，但这可能是我职业生涯早期学到的第一件事。而且它可能，它可能甚至在她之前，人们就想到了它，但我们的大脑只允许那种强度持续很短的时间。所以正是在海洋的那些海啸波浪之间，那种喘息使我们能够处理我们的悲伤。甚至Victor Frankel也在他关于刺激和反应的精彩引语中谈到了这一点。正是在
the stimulus and response that we can work towards our freedom. And from my perspective, that growth, right, with our grief. And so I think going back to your question, learning that tool, and then what do we do in between that stimulus and response to help our clients? And that's where the somatic piece really grew for me. Yeah, I remember when I worked in hospice as like a social work student that I would notice that when I was getting people close to kind of an acceptance or realization of something, some part of their body would start to hurt and become intensely, like overwhelmingly activated. And then it would pop and release and they would express insight and they would express resolution. And so I didn't really know what I was doing, you know, like, but I knew pretty early on that if I could ask, like, where do you feel that in your body?
刺激和反应之间，我们可以努力争取我们的自由。从我的角度来看，那种成长，对吧，伴随着我们的悲伤。所以我认为回到你的问题，学习那个工具，然后我们在刺激和反应之间做什么来帮助我们的客户？这就是躯体部分对我来说真正成长的地方。是的，我记得当我在临终关怀中心做社会工作学生时，我注意到当我让人们接近某种接受或对某事的领悟时，他们身体的某个部位会开始疼痛并变得极其强烈地、压倒性地激活。然后它会爆发并释放，他们会表达洞察力，他们会表达解决。所以我真的不知道我在做什么，你知道，但我很早就知道，如果我能问，比如，“你在身体的哪里感觉到那个？”
Or like when you sit without emotion, what changes for you physically? You could push people through that cycle faster, you know, the real resolution. And then and then the next, you know, 15 years was building a language to understand that thing. But if you kind of have to have that ability to see that connection between the brain and the body and that, you know, they are waves that kind of move of energy that and that, you know, they are waves that kind of move of energy that move around, you know, not to beat you. There's a lot of scientific language that we've got now, but there is a connection. And this idea that the body is just this go-kart that carries the brain around is kind of going out, even though academia and the AMA don't really
或者“当你坐着没有情绪时，你在身体上有什么变化？”你可以推动人们更快地通过那个循环，你知道，真正的解决。然后接下来的15年就是建立一种语言来理解那个东西。但如果你必须有那种能力看到大脑和身体之间的联系，并且你知道，它们是某种能量的波浪，它们四处移动，你知道，不是为了打败你。我们现在有很多科学语言，但确实存在一种联系。而且这种认为身体只是一个带着大脑到处跑的卡丁车的想法正在过时，尽管学术界和美国医学会（AMA）并不真的
want it to, um, in clinical practice, it just sort of has to leave because it doesn't work. And I don't know. I mean, it seems so when you're doing training, when you're preparing somebody who's going to go in, who's a social work student, who's a, you know, an LPC or a clinical psychologist, and they've heard this stuff for a really long time. What's your licensure? What are you licensed as? Yeah, I'm a licensed clinical social worker and also I'm a yoga teacher. Me too. I was just curious about how, if your educational experience was any different from mine, but it sounds like based on what you said before, it probably was similar. But the, yeah, when you, when you come in to the room and you, you say I'm, I'm 20, I've never even had a child, let alone lost one. I don't, I can't understand. I can't relate to this person's experience. Yeah. I can't tie it back to something that I know.
想要它过时，但在临床实践中，它只是不得不离开，因为它行不通。我不知道。我的意思是，这看起来……当你进行培训时，当你准备一个即将进入该领域的人，一个社会工作学生，一个LPC（持证专业咨询师）或临床心理学家，他们已经听了很长时间这些东西。你的执照是什么？你拥有什么执照？是的，我是一名持证临床社会工作者（LCSW），我也是一名瑜伽老师。我也是。我只是好奇你的教育经历是否与我的有任何不同，但听起来根据你之前所说的，它可能很相似。但是，是的，当你走进房间，你说“我20岁，我甚至从未有过孩子，更不用说失去一个了。我不，我无法理解。我无法与这个人的经历产生共鸣。”是的。我无法把它与我知道的事情联系起来。
And there's this insecurity that a younger person has. What would they learn at your trainings? You know, what would they learn from your experience or in work with you to be able to help, help someone with that? Yeah. I'm actually glad you brought that up because, first of all, I recently gave a workshop to about 70 Parkinson's patients and their caregivers. And at the beginning of the presentation, some of them were saying, well, I haven't experienced grief. And I thought it took me back for a minute, but it's because we think of it as death and dying, right? And in reality, in that training, in that first 20 minutes, we started talking about where have you experienced loss? And so that was really profound for them. And I mean, from my
而且一个年轻人会有这种不安全感。他们在你的培训中学到了什么？你知道，他们会从你的经验中或在与你一起工作中学习到什么，从而能够帮助别人处理这个问题？是的。我其实很高兴你提到了这一点，因为首先，我最近给大约70名帕金森病患者及其护理人员举办了一个研讨会。在演讲开始时，他们中的一些人说，“嗯，我没有经历过悲伤。”我想这让我退缩了一分钟，但这是因为我们认为它是关于死亡和临终，对吧？实际上，在那个培训中，在那最初的20分钟里，我们开始谈论“你在哪里经历过丧失？”所以这对他们来说非常深刻。我的意思是，从我的
perspective as a professional, I thought you're losing your sense of independence and health and your caregiver or your partner is losing the activities they used to do with you, but they didn't even think about it in that way until they started talking about it of recognizing, yeah, I have had loss, right? And so even in these trainings, if I have, you know, a newer social worker that has not experienced the death of a loved one, maybe they're younger, maybe a parent hasn't died or, you know, God forbid they haven't had a, hopefully they'll never have a child that dies. In that experience, we start talking about like, where are these losses in your life and recognizing that accumulation loss, you know, as we talked
专业角度来看，我想你正在失去你的独立感和健康，而你的护理人员或你的伴侣正在失去他们过去和你一起做的活动，但他们甚至没有以那种方式思考它，直到他们开始谈论它，意识到“是的，我确实经历过丧失，”对吧？所以即使在这些培训中，如果我有一个没有经历过亲人死亡的较新的社会工作者，也许他们更年轻，也许父母没有去世，或者，上帝保佑，他们没有经历过孩子死亡。在那种经历中，我们开始谈论“你生活中的这些丧失在哪里？”并认识到那种累积的丧失，你知道，正如我们在
about at the beginning of the podcast, even a proposal being denied by your boss, that's a little loss, right? And so if we start there of saying, hey, we all have these experiences. And if we don't work with them in our body, it's going to accumulate. And if we learn how to work with some of these like, quote, smaller losses, right, we then learn the tools for then when we do experience bigger losses, because we all do. It's like, like I've shared many times before, that's the one thing none of us are immune from, right? Then maybe we have the capacity to stay in our window a little bit longer, or we learn how to get back into that window, that window of being able to continue to go on, you know, every day. And when the time comes and we feel like we need extra support, there's so many grief resources
播客开始时谈到的那样，即使是一个提案被老板拒绝，那也是一个小小的丧失，对吧？所以如果我们从那里开始说，“嘿，我们都有这些经历。如果我们不在身体里处理它们，它就会累积。如果我们学会如何处理这些所谓的‘较小’的丧失，对吧，我们就会学到工具，以便在我们经历更大的丧失时（因为我们所有人都会经历），我们就有能力应对。”就像我之前多次分享的那样，那是我们谁都无法免疫的一件事，对吧？那么也许我们有能力在我们的窗口内停留更长时间，或者我们学会如何回到那个窗口，那个能够继续前进的窗口，你知道，每一天。当时间到来，我们觉得我们需要额外的支持时，有太多的悲伤资源
out there, many different grief theories and grief support groups. I will say a piece that's missing in all these theories is that somatic piece. So that's our hope is we teach these tools so they can then implement them into some of, let's say they run a grief group, right? And it's not just about, you know, telling their story and what they're going to do to focus in on the loss and then focus in on what they need to do every day of their life. But what are the going to do to focus in on the loss and then focus in on the, um, what they need to do every day of their life, but what are the tools to help them be on those sides? Well, and you say holistic grief a lot in your materials. And I mean, I like when I hear things like that, because I know that the person isn't just selling avoidance as the cure. And I think a lot of times
在那里，许多不同的悲伤理论和悲伤支持小组。我会说所有这些理论中缺失的一块是那个躯体部分。所以这就是我们的希望，我们教授这些工具，这样他们就可以将它们实施到他们的一些……假设他们经营一个悲伤小组，对吧？这不仅仅是关于，你知道，讲述他们的故事，以及他们将要做什么来专注于丧失，然后专注于他们每天生活中需要做的事情。但是，他们将要做什么来专注于丧失，然后专注于……他们每天生活中需要做的事情，但是，帮助他们处理那些方面的工具是什么？好吧，你在你的材料中经常提到“整体悲伤”（holistic grief）。我的意思是，当我听到这样的事情时，我很高兴，因为我知道这个人不仅仅是在兜售回避作为治愈方法。我认为很多时候
very medicalized psychotherapy and brief treatment, all those models that came out in the 90s that have solution focused or something in front of them. A lot of it is just, hey, think about something else. Now you're better in the room. Now I can pretend you're better forever. But there's not a growth. There's not an integration. You're just sort of moving something from anxiety to somatics or from the somatic reality to that one. Do you see that? Like, do you see people who felt like they did the work or tried to get help and it didn't work
非常医学化的心理治疗和简短治疗，所有那些在90年代出现并在前面带有“以解决方案为中心”之类的模型。很多只是，“嘿，想点别的事情。现在你在房间里好转了。现在我可以假装你永远好转了。”但没有成长。没有整合。你只是在把某种东西从焦虑转移到躯体，或者从躯体现实转移到那个。你看到了吗？比如，你是否看到那些觉得他们做了工作或试图寻求帮助但没有奏效的人，
and then come to you and that they make some kind of connection? 100%. Yes. And that's because they're so focused on the brain and talking and they're not working with where they're really holding their grief, which is a big part of their body, maybe in their heart, maybe in their belly, right? And so if we can do work on these tools to help within their body, then they can work towards growing with their grief. Do you have any kind of examples of how yoga plays into that, how you use yoga? Yes, yes. So yoga, I mean, the breath work is big, right? You know, the simplest one that we all use that maybe those of us that aren't in the yoga world is that longer exhale. But a lot of times we will say, well, how do you do that? Right. And so it can be that longer inhale, the slower inhale,
然后来到你这里，他们建立某种联系？百分之百。是的。这是因为他们太专注于大脑和谈话，而没有处理他们真正保持悲伤的地方，这很大一部分是在他们的身体里，也许在他们的心里，也许在他们的肚子里，对吧？所以如果我们能做这些工具的工作来帮助他们的身体，那么他们就能努力与他们的悲伤一起成长。你有什么关于瑜伽如何发挥作用的例子吗，你是如何使用瑜伽的？是的，是的。所以瑜伽，我的意思是，呼吸练习很重要，对吧？你知道，我们所有人都使用的最简单的一个，也许我们这些不在瑜伽世界的人使用的是那种更长的呼气。但很多时候我们会说，“好吧，你怎么做呢？”对吧。所以它可以是那种更长的吸气，更慢的吸气，
and then the even slower exhale through straw breath, like breathing slowly through a straw. And there's many more that I, if this was a five hour podcast, I'd go through them because I feel passionate about them. But the other piece is anything that relates to contraction and expansion is a lot about how we grow with our grief and trauma, right? Like we expand heart opening, opening our arms up, and that's allowing that vulnerability for people to see us for who we are and be able to support us. And then at the opposite, we contract in when we need some time just to be with our grief on our own. And if you can pendulate back and forth, that's a huge way we can work towards growing
然后通过吸管呼吸（straw breath）进行更慢的呼气，就像通过吸管缓慢呼吸一样。还有很多我……如果这是一个五小时的播客，我会讲完它们，因为我对它们充满热情。但另一部分是任何与收缩和扩张有关的东西，这很大程度上关于我们如何与我们的悲伤和创伤一起成长，对吧？比如我们扩张，打开心扉，张开双臂，这就是允许那种脆弱性，让人们看到我们本来的样子，并能够支持我们。然后相反，当我们只需要一些时间独自与我们的悲伤相处时，我们就会收缩。如果你能来回摆动（pendulate），这是我们努力与我们的经历和悲伤一起成长的一种巨大方式。
with our experience and our grief. And so, you know, walking meditations are another one, that bilateral stimulation for those that know trauma, right? EMDR, even just that intentional walking or swimming is another way to work with our grief, getting in touch with both sides of the brain as we're working and processing our experiences. Do you ever do anything with labyrinths, walking labyrinths or figure labyrinths? That's kind of. Yeah, we actually we have a grief retreat coming up that has a beautiful labyrinth in November. And absolutely, that's a big piece to be able to do that. Yeah. And even if someone doesn't have a labyrinth, they can go to a park. Right. And just do their own labyrinth in circles, slowly going in with going in within themselves and then slowly walking back out. How do I go back out into this world when I feel like the world is continuing and I am not?
所以，你知道，行走冥想是另一种，对于那些了解创伤的人来说，那是双侧刺激（bilateral stimulation），对吧？EMDR（眼动脱敏再加工），甚至只是那种有意的行走或游泳也是处理我们悲伤的另一种方式，在我们工作和处理我们的经历时，与大脑的两侧取得联系。你做过任何关于迷宫（labyrinths）、行走迷宫或图形迷宫的事情吗？那有点……是的，我们实际上……我们有一个即将到来的悲伤静修会，在11月有一个美丽的迷宫。绝对，那是能够做到这一点的重要部分。是的。即使某人没有迷宫，他们也可以去公园。对吧。只是做他们自己的圆圈迷宫，缓慢地走进他们自己内心，然后缓慢地走出来。当我感觉世界在继续而我没有时，我该如何回到这个世界上？
How do you see like the biggest misconceptions out there in the field? You know, other than just that the emotions are not somatic and that, you know, trauma doesn't have a somatic root at its end, you know, what do you see as like people talking about grief and you just hear it and you're like, oh, no, that's wrong. Yeah, that's a good question. So I'm going to give a lot of fondness to Elizabeth Kugler-Ross. And in her work, she brought grief to the forefront and how people, she believed, experienced grief. And she did amazing work. However, the work she did was with terminally ill patients. It was not with caregivers. And so I think the biggest misconception out there is there really aren't set stages. There's many different ways people experience their grief.
你如何看待该领域中最大的误解？你知道，除了情绪不是躯体的，以及创伤在最后没有躯体根源之外，你知道，你认为人们谈论悲伤时，你听到它，你会觉得，“哦，不，那是错的。”是的，这是一个好问题。所以我对Elizabeth Kubler-Ross怀有很大的敬意。在她的工作中，她把悲伤带到了最前沿，以及她认为人们是如何经历悲伤的。她做了了不起的工作。然而，她所做的工作是针对绝症患者的。它不是针对护理人员的。所以我认为外面最大的误解是，真的没有设定的阶段。人们经历悲伤的方式有很多种。
And it's not a beginning and an end. And so I think that's still talked a lot about in the grief or in the popular culture, popular world to recognize that it's a lot of chaos. Right. When we're experiencing it, it's not linear. And she knew that in her work. It's just, it got a little bit misconstrued over the years. So I would say that's a big area that needs to be talked more about is that it's not a linear progression. Yeah. The belief was that you go through the stages of grief like this. And if you go through them in this order, you're doing it right. And if you get stuck, you're doing it wrong.
它不是一个开始和一个结束。所以我认为这在悲伤领域或流行文化、流行世界中仍然被谈论很多，要认识到它有很多混乱。对吧。当我们经历它时，它不是线性的。她在她的工作中知道这一点。只是，多年来它被稍微曲解了。所以我认为这是一个需要更多谈论的大领域，即它不是一个线性的过程。是的。当时的信念是你像这样经历悲伤的阶段。如果你按这个顺序经历它们，你就做对了。如果你卡住了，你就做错了。
Or if you go back, what you're doing wrong, is that what you mean? Well, and another thing about those stages of grief is like, I use those with almost all my patients because what they're describing is how we pretend that our emotional reality can have power over an external reality. Like, oh, my anger is magic i'm not gonna let that happen this isn't allowed i'm gonna act like my dad did when something wasn't allowed doesn't matter he's dead you know well it doesn't change anything i'm not i'm not gonna let this happen i'm gonna get up and make coffee like it doesn't matter she's you know there's the there are ways
或者如果你回去，你做错了，这就是你的意思吗？好吧，关于那些悲伤阶段的另一件事是，我几乎对我所有的病人都使用它们，因为他们所描述的是我们如何假装我们的情感现实可以对外部现实拥有权力。比如，“哦，我的愤怒是魔法，我不会让那发生，这是不允许的，我会像我爸爸那样做，当某事不被允许时，没关系，他死了，”你知道，好吧，它什么也没改变，我不会，我不会让这发生，我会起床去煮咖啡，好像没关系，她……你知道，有那些
that we deflect from an emotional reality and everybody everybody deflects like that, even if it's that I don't want to do my taxes. Like everyone deflects and says anger is magic. You know, like, well, if I don't think about it, it doesn't exist. You know, well, if I, you know, all of those, all of those things. And so I use them all the time. Like you've heard of brain spotting or emotional transformation therapy. Do you have any overlap yes yeah so we do a little bit differently because emotional transformation therapy is a lot of devices but it's like light color some other stuff we combine that a little bit with brain spotting
我们从情感现实中回避的方式，每个人，每个人都那样回避，即使是“我不想报税”。就像每个人都回避并说愤怒是魔法。你知道，比如，“好吧，如果我不去想它，它就不存在。”你知道，好吧，如果我……所有那些，所有那些事情。所以我一直使用它们。就像你听说过脑点疗法（brain spotting）或情绪转化疗法（emotional transformation therapy）吗？你有任何重叠吗？是的，是的，所以我们做得有点不同，因为情绪转化疗法有很多设备，但它就像光、颜色和其他一些东西，我们把那一点点与脑点疗法结合起来，
and you can see the pupil where you're on a spot but the person doesn't really want to go through it there's this resistance where it shrinks back down and you see that like sympathetic nervous system being like no i'm all in my head i'm all in my neocortex right now and i will not feel that and i'm always like because they're and i always like when i see that i ask the patient like hey it looks like you're telling me no and they're confused because they're not talking and i'm like no it looks like there's something that's like i will not go there i won't go there don't take this away from me i need this do you feel that energy and they're not thinking of anything consciously a lot of times like yeah i do what is that i'm like think about you're trying to wait make this energy go
你可以看到瞳孔，你在一个点上，但那个人真的不想经历它，有一种阻力，它缩了回去，你看到那个交感神经系统就像，“不，我完全在我的脑子里，我完全在我的新皮层里，我不会感觉到那个，”我总是……因为他们……当我看到那个时，我总是问病人，“嘿，看起来你在告诉我‘不’，”他们很困惑，因为他们没有说话，我说，“不，看起来有什么东西就像‘我不会去那里，我不会去那里，别把这个从我这里拿走，我需要这个’，你感觉到那种能量了吗？”他们很多时候并没有有意识地思考任何事情，就像，“是的，我感觉到了，那是什么？”我说，“想想你正在试图让这种能量消失，
away or you're trying to make this energy you're waiting until it's over or just outlast it or wait until somebody takes it away from you you know whatever metaphor works none of that's happening this is going to be here forever this is an emotional arc that you have to complete it's never going to go away how can you be bigger than it how can you be bigger than around it a lot of times i'll try and make them yawn because it makes the parasympathetic nervous system flare up and then all of a sudden because i yawned i can't be panicking anymore because i gotta and and then you see the eye slowly start to wibble and then open and it dilates really big and then they are just so tired and they think i made them tired and i'm like no that's how tired you were underneath this amount
或者你正在试图让这种能量……你正在等待直到它结束，或者只是熬过它，或者等待直到有人把它从你这里拿走，”你知道，无论什么隐喻有效，这些都没有发生，这会永远在这里，这是一个你必须完成的情感弧线，它永远不会消失，你如何能比它更大？你如何能比它更大，围绕着它？很多时候，我会尝试让他们打哈欠，因为它使副交感神经系统爆发，然后突然之间，因为我打哈欠了，我不能再恐慌了，因为我必须……然后你看到眼睛慢慢开始颤动，然后睁开，它扩张得非常大，然后他们只是太累了，他们认为我让他们累了，我说，“不，那是你在这股焦虑之下有多累，”
of anxiety that's right you know maybe for a year this is how you were supposed to feel um but the thing is i did hypnosis like i did emdr i did uh a lot of like yungian and experiential therapies i did gestalt therapy you know for years before I ever knew the brain spotting existed. So like a lot of it, you still see that same arc, you know, it's, it's funny when it's an eye and you've got this visual representation, but do you, do you see things like that? Or is that, is that relevant kind of to, to, I'm trying to tie the stages of grief and back to the somatic reality.
那是对的，你知道，也许有一年，这就是你应该有的感觉。嗯，但问题是，我做了催眠，我做了EMDR，我做了很多像荣格和体验式疗法，我做了格式塔疗法（gestalt therapy），你知道，在我知道脑点疗法存在之前的几年。所以，很多时候，你仍然看到同样的弧线，你知道，当它是一只眼睛并且你有这种视觉表现时，这很有趣，但你，你看到类似的事情吗？或者那是，那是相关的吗，对于……我正试图把悲伤阶段和躯体现实联系起来。
Cause I do think the body and the brain are kind of doing the same thing, which is pretending that they can control something they can't control. And there has to be a release and acceptance. Yes. I would agree with you. Yes, it definitely, I think maybe the caveat with all of that is that it's the stages aren't in a row, right? And I think that's the pieces that these stages, maybe think of them more as like play sets, right? In our circle of grief that we experience different ones at different times. A hundred percent, we experience denial and anger and bargaining and, you know, all the different, there's many out there. I mean, many theorists since Elizabeth Kubler-Ross have come up with many, many more too, right? And so absolutely we experience those emotions and those feelings on a regular basis. And, but not everyone experiences all of them either, right? And maybe someone experiences a lot of them
因为我确实认为身体和大脑在做同样的事情，那就是假装它们可以控制它们无法控制的东西。必须有一种释放和接受。是的。我会同意你的看法。是的，它绝对……我想所有这些的警告可能是阶段不是按顺序排列的，对吧？我认为这就是那些阶段的碎片，也许把它们更多地看作是游戏集，对吧？在我们经历的悲伤循环中，我们在不同的时间经历不同的阶段。百分之百，我们经历否认、愤怒、讨价还价，你知道，所有不同的，外面有很多。我的意思是，自Elizabeth Kubler-Ross以来，许多理论家也提出了更多更多，对吧？所以我们绝对会定期经历那些情绪和感受。但是，并不是每个人都经历所有这些，对吧？也许有人经历了很多，
and then years go by and they have another loss because surprise, loss is always knocking at our door. And then they experience those plus some more the next time, or maybe what they experienced the first time they don't, right? But the other part that I think is so important is, you know, when I say loss is always knocking at your door, I will say I'm very much a strength-based therapist, and I'm going to give a lot of credit to Deb Dana, who works with Dr. Stephen Porges, and she did a beautiful job of making the language more accessible to the general public. And so one of her beautiful gifts are glimmers, right? And so we have triggers all the time around loss. We can also find those glimmers, those places of hope, like connection, right? That co-regulation with another human being, like going outside and in grief work, I tease
然后几年过去了，他们又有了另一次丧失，因为惊喜，丧失总是敲我们的门。然后他们下一次经历那些加上更多，或者也许他们第一次经历的他们没有，对吧？但我觉得非常重要的另一部分是，你知道，当我说丧失总是敲你的门时，我会说我非常是一个基于优势的治疗师，我要给Deb Dana很多赞誉，她与Stephen Porges博士一起工作，她做了一件漂亮的工作，使语言对公众更容易理解。所以她美丽的礼物之一是“闪光”（glimmers），对吧？所以我们一直有关于丧失的触发点。我们也可以找到那些闪光，那些希望的地方，比如连接，对吧？那种与另一个人的人际共同调节，比如走到外面，在悲伤工作中，我开玩笑说
some of my kid clients and say, you know, all of our grief is triggered by the five senses. And so they'll try to convince me, no, it's not Amy. You know, they'll say, no, no, no, no, that's not true. You know, the other day I was walking down the street and I saw this guy and it reminded me of my dad. I said, that's sight, right? And so, but then it's also important to note that all the glimmers are triggered by senses too, the five senses. And so we can have these triggers of loss when we see something and smell something and remind us of that experience of loss but we can also have these beautiful glimmers of you know this woman sat next to me the other day and um i didn't know her very well but she just checked in with me she noticed i was sad and it reminded me of my grandmother
我的一些儿童客户会说，你知道，我们所有的悲伤都是由五种感官触发的。他们会试图说服我，不，艾米，不是这样的。你知道，他们会说，不不不，那不是真的。你知道，前几天我走在街上，看到一个人，让我想起了我的父亲。我说，那是视觉，对吧？所以，但同样重要的是要注意，所有的“闪光点”（glimmers）也是由感官触发的，即五种感官。因此，当我们看到或闻到某些东西并想起那种失落的经历时，我们可能会产生失落的触发点，但我们也会有那些美好的“闪光点”，比如前几天这位女士坐在我旁边，嗯，我不太了解她，但她主动关心我，她注意到我很伤心，这让我想起了我的祖母。
right and it was a beautiful thing thing. And do you have like the name Light Movement and then some of your work before you that leads you up to that? Can you talk about your personal experience or the way the decisions to structure the nonprofit and the trainings in the way that you do? Yes, I would be honored to. And this is where at the beginning you say you like to tell a little joke and I'll add a little bit of humor in it. So, you know, I've been a grief therapist for many, many years. During COVID, our youngest son, we have three children, had some major health issues. And so we had to be home longer than most until he was vaccinated per his medical providers. And so my parents were huge supports for us during this time. And, but tragically during COVID, there was a freak accident. We were camping with my parents
没错，那是一件美好的事情。你是否有“光之运动”（Light Movement）这个名字，以及在你做这件事之前的一些工作经历？你能谈谈你的个人经历，或者你决定以这种方式构建非营利组织和培训的原因吗？是的，我很荣幸。这就是开头你说的你喜欢讲个小笑话的地方，我也加点幽默感。所以，你知道，我做悲伤治疗师已经很多很多年了。在新冠疫情期间，我们最小的儿子，我们有三个孩子，出现了一些重大的健康问题。因此，在医疗提供者建议他接种疫苗之前，我们不得不比大多数人待在家里更久。所以我的父母在这段时间里给了我们巨大的支持。但是，悲剧的是，在新冠疫情期间，发生了一起离奇的事故。我们当时正和我的父母一起露营。
and my parents own an RV, we don't, but they did. And he went to close his gate and there was a huge wind storm, which isn't super common in Denver compared to maybe other places in the country. And unfortunately the wind, the gate blew him over and he fell on his head and he ended up with a brain bleed. And two days later, we withdrew life support. Now, I'm going to backtrack a little bit. And that was a very, very hard, obviously very hard experience for our family.
我的父母有一辆房车，我们没有，但他们有。他去关门时，突然刮起了一场大风暴，这在丹佛并不常见，相比国内其他地方而言。不幸的是，风把门吹开了，撞倒了他，他头部着地，最终导致脑出血。两天后，我们撤除了生命维持系统。现在，我要稍微回顾一下。那对我们家庭来说显然是一次非常、非常艰难的经历。
And but I'm going to backtrack previously because I think this is really important and this is really what's motivated all of this. During my career, my dad was an attorney and he was a very, he was known as a humble giant and he was six foot five and he spoke nationally on mandated reporting. He was an education lawyer and preventing school violence. And his last big hurrah was to ensure all students, he wanted all students to have safe public restrooms and public schools, including transgender youth. And so he did these beautiful things for our country. And he always said to me, Amy, you should speak to your work in the death and dying. And I always
但我还是要回顾一下之前的情况，因为我认为这非常重要，这也是这一切的动力所在。在我的职业生涯中，我的父亲是一名律师，他被称为“谦逊的巨人”，他身高六英尺五英寸，曾在全国范围内就强制报告制度发表演讲。他是一名教育律师，致力于预防校园暴力。他最后的一大壮举是确保所有学生，他希望所有学生都能在公立学校使用安全的公共洗手间，包括跨性别青年。所以他为我们的国家做了这些美好的事情。他总是对我说：“艾米，你应该谈谈你在死亡和临终关怀方面的工作。”而我总是……
said, dad, I am a psychotherapist. I'm not a public speaker. No, thank you. But he always really encouraged me. So fast forward, we had, he had that horrible fall and he died. And during my grief work for my own self, my dad's always kept coming to me, but I was so busy during that time caring for my three kids, my mom, you know, my husband was amazing during that time. But I also saw in my practice, it went by the wayside. Well, then fast forward to last year, March of 2023, which is actually my birthday. And my husband and I finally got a weekend away. And we went to Ojo Caliente, which are these hot springs outside Taos, New Mexico. And my husband's a huge mountaineer and rock climber.
说：“爸爸，我是心理治疗师，不是公众演说家。不，谢谢。”但他总是非常鼓励我。快进到后来，他摔倒了，不幸去世了。在我为自己进行悲伤辅导的过程中，父亲总是出现在我的脑海里，但当时我太忙了，要照顾三个孩子和我母亲，你知道，我丈夫在那段时间里表现得非常棒。但我也看到我的诊所工作被搁置了。好吧，快进到去年，2023年3月，那其实是我的生日。我和丈夫终于有了一个周末的假期。我们去了新墨西哥州陶斯郊外的奥霍卡连特（Ojo Caliente）温泉。我丈夫是个狂热的登山者和攀岩者。
And so, of course, we're at the hot springs. And he says, let's go for a hike. And I said, Sure, we'll go for a hike. So we climbed up this big mesa to this beautiful mica mine, we got up there and there were shimmering diamonds. It was so beautiful. But I knew we had to go back down. And I knew it was very steep going up. So we started down the path. And about a third of the way down this mesa, there was this juniper tree that was strutting out from the ground. And I held on to the juniper tree. I hugged it being the vegan hippie that I am. My husband is not a vegan or a hippie. And he said, yes, Amy, I'm sure this tree has helped a lot of people. I said, I know this tree has helped a lot of people. Well, fast forward the last part of the
所以，当然，我们在温泉。他说：“我们去徒步吧。”我说：“好，我们去徒步。”于是我们爬上了一座大平顶山，来到一个美丽的云母矿，到了那里，到处都是闪闪发光的钻石。太美了。但我知道我们必须回去。而且我知道上山的路非常陡。所以我们开始沿路下山。在下到平顶山大约三分之一的地方，有一棵杜松树从地里伸出来。我抓住了那棵杜松树。我拥抱了它，毕竟我是个素食嬉皮士。我丈夫不是素食主义者，也不是嬉皮士。他说：“是的，艾米，我相信这棵树一定帮过很多人。”我说：“我知道这棵树帮过很多人。”好吧，快进到最后一段……
hike right before we're getting into the hot springs. It's like the steepest part. And my husband said, do you want me to lead? And I said, no, it's my birthday. I'm leading this hike. And I started down this last steep part and I tripped and I fell. I fell 40 feet. I ended up with 600 cactus spines. I ended up with a fractured tibia, a severe concussion, but I should have fallen a hundred feet, but something stopped me in the path where I only fell 40 and thus I'm alive today. Do you know what that was? The tree? It was another juniper tree. Oh, wow.
徒步旅行，就在我们进入温泉之前。那是路最陡的部分。我丈夫问：“要我带路吗？”我说：“不，今天是我的生日，我来带路。”我开始走下最后这段陡坡，结果被绊倒了，摔了下去。我摔了40英尺。身上扎了600根仙人掌刺。我胫骨骨折，脑震荡严重，但我本该摔下100英尺的，但路中间有什么东西挡住了我，所以我只摔了40英尺，因此我今天还活着。你知道那是什么吗？那棵树？是另一棵杜松树。哦，天哪。
So the juniper tree stopped my fall. My husband was, you know, rushed down in adrenaline. We rushed to the hospital. And the nurse in the emergency room was like, you know about duct tape? Duct tape is going to pull all these spines out, but you got a year with these spines. So that's my little bit of humor. So obviously I'm not going to duct tape my hair, but we did use duct tape on many other parts of my arms and legs and belly and bum. And so anyway, we're there doing all these.
所以那棵杜松树阻止了我的坠落。我丈夫当时肾上腺素飙升，冲了下来。我们赶往医院。急诊室的护士说：“你知道胶带吗？胶带可以把这些刺拔出来，但你得带着这些刺过一年。”这就是我的一点幽默。显然我不会用胶带粘我的头发，但我们确实在我的手臂、腿、肚子和屁股的其他部位用了胶带。总之，我们在那里做所有这些……
Do the spines stay in? I'm not familiar with this. They do. You can't just rip them out? They do. You've got to wait until they're. Oh, some you can't, you can't just rip them out. You've got to wait. You can rip out the really big ones. Like my husband pulled about a two inch one outside, like right by my spinal column, but the really tiny ones,
刺会留在里面吗？我不熟悉这个。会的。你不能直接拔出来吗？不能。你得等它们……哦，有些你不能直接拔出来。你得等。你可以拔掉那些特别大的。比如我丈夫在我脊柱旁边拔掉了一根大约两英寸长的，但那些非常细小的……
they stay in there for a very long time. Yes. So they check all my belly or check all my body. The good news is I did not have a brain bleed. I was terrified. I had a brain bleed, which is how my dad died. Um, my husband, they finally discharged us and they, my husband goes to get the car. Um, he comes back to get me in the waiting room. I fully pass out again. And, and I fully passed, he comes in, they readmit me. They want to make sure I didn't have a belly bleed. The good news is I did not have a belly bleed, but they found a mass in my belly. They told me to get back to Denver quickly.
它们会在里面待很长时间。是的。所以他们检查了我的肚子，或者检查了我的全身。好消息是我没有脑出血。我当时吓坏了，以为自己脑出血了，我父亲就是那样去世的。嗯，我丈夫，他们终于让我们出院了，我丈夫去取车。他回到候诊室接我。我再次完全昏倒了。他进来，他们又让我重新入院。他们想确保我没有腹部出血。好消息是我没有腹部出血，但他们在我的肚子里发现了一个肿块。他们让我赶紧回丹佛。
They did some scans and it turns out I had cancer. So the juniper tree saved my life twice. And so in this time of recovery last summer, my dad's voice profoundly came back to me over and over again and said, Amy, it's your time to start speaking to this journey of death and dying and grief and loss. And so last year at this time in September, this is very significant. And I'll tell you why in just a minute, we got a group of 50 volunteers together to hold a solstice event on December 21st. And I offered a somatic-based talk. It's
他们做了一些扫描，结果发现我得了癌症。所以那棵杜松树救了我两次命。在去年夏天康复期间，我父亲的声音深刻地一次又一次地回到我耳边，他说：“艾米，是时候开始谈论这段关于死亡、临终、悲伤和失落的旅程了。”所以去年这个时候，在九月，这非常有意义。我一会儿告诉你为什么。我们召集了50名志愿者，在12月21日举办了一场冬至活动。我做了一场基于躯体疗法的演讲。它……
on our website. And we had these faith representatives from every potential faith we could find. So Christian, Muslim, Jewish, Buddhist, Native American, as many people to come in solidarity, to stand in solidarity for all people and all types of grief. Now, September is significant because this was right before the horror of Gaza and Israel. And so we planned it. Then this happened, and yet we were still able to bring these faith representatives together and say, we believe that we all have to support all people and all not done. And so a group of volunteers, we formed this nonprofit that literally got 501c3 status this summer. And our goal is globally to teach these tools and from a social justice lens. So let's say someone from Africa takes our training and says, I love this, but I need a more fit for what fits for the people I work with. We hope they do that. Right. And so our message is global. It's, you know, Colorado nation and world to be able to get these messages out to support people
在我们的网站上。我们邀请了来自我们能找到的每一个潜在信仰的代表。所以有基督教、伊斯兰教、犹太教、佛教、美洲原住民，尽可能多的人团结一致，为所有人以及各种类型的悲伤站在一起。现在，九月之所以重要，是因为这正好发生在加沙和以色列的恐怖事件之前。所以我们计划好了。然后发生了这件事，但我们仍然能够把这些信仰代表聚集在一起，说：“我们相信我们必须支持所有人，而不是……”所以一群志愿者，我们成立了这个非营利组织，今年夏天正式获得了501c3免税地位。我们的目标是在全球范围内以社会正义的视角教授这些工具。假设非洲有人参加了我们的培训并说：“我喜欢这个，但我需要更适合我所服务人群的内容。”我们希望他们能这样做。没错。所以我们的信息是全球性的。你知道，科罗拉多、全国乃至全世界，能够将这些信息传达出去，支持人们……
in their grief. And we did it and we've done it in such a short amount of time. And so we have trainings and these, and a retreat we're starting, our classroom platform is going to build exponentially. Our hope is we get someone in your state to take our workshop and then say, I want to volunteer for light. Our training is actually is tiered and it's very cheap for people that want to volunteer for our nonprofit. And so let's say someone said, I want to teach a class here and we'll do the donations to the light movement. Our training is really cheap for that reason, because we want to really expand it. And obviously our hope is we can get some donors donations in as well to, to make our mission. But right now we're all volunteers. How many people would you need to do a training like at Birmingham? Cause there's a couple of the clinical directors around that
在他们的悲伤中。我们做到了，而且我们在如此短的时间内就做到了。所以我们有培训，还有我们正在开始的静修，我们的课堂平台将呈指数级增长。我们希望能在你们州找到人参加我们的研讨会，然后说：“我想为‘光’做志愿者。”我们的培训实际上是分级的，对于想为我们非营利组织做志愿者的人来说非常便宜。所以假设有人说：“我想在这里教一门课，我们会把捐款捐给‘光之运动’。”我们的培训之所以很便宜，是因为我们真的想扩大它。显然，我们希望也能得到一些捐款来完成我们的使命。但目前我们都是志愿者。在伯明翰这样的地方做一次培训，你需要多少人？因为周围有几个临床主任……
have smaller practices or independent clinicians. I'll say like, Hey, we could all save some travel costs if we can try and get this new treatment to this area. Because that was our clinic's mission with brain spotting. Nobody did it. Everybody thought it was crazy. And now it's like, we're covered up with brain spotting providers in Birmingham. We've promoted it and talked about it and done all this stuff. So that might be about how many would you need to do a training locally? That's a great question. I would say, I mean, in a beautiful world, we could get around 50, but our training is virtual as well. So people can tune in online. We have both. Right now we're doing an in-person and virtual.
他们有较小的诊所或独立的临床医生。我会说：“嘿，如果我们能尝试把这种新疗法带到这个地区，我们都可以节省一些差旅费。”因为那曾是我们诊所关于“脑点疗法”（brain spotting）的使命。没人做。大家都觉得它很疯狂。而现在，伯明翰到处都是脑点疗法提供者。我们推广了它，谈论了它，做了所有这些事情。所以，在当地做一次培训大概需要多少人？这是个好问题。我会说，在理想的情况下，我们能召集到50人左右，但我们的培训也是虚拟的。所以人们可以在线收听。我们两者都有。目前我们正在进行线下和虚拟培训。
We may switch to just virtual as well. And we'll offer this training in October, and then we're going to offer it again in February or March. So we'll do a 20 hour in October. I know right now on our website, it says a 40 hour, the 20 hours for like anyone, anyone and everyone. The one in the spring will also be another 20 hour plus another 20 hours for any yoga teachers to become grief sensitive and trauma informed practitioners. Is that something that like a social worker or LPC would get a CE for?
我们可能也会转为纯虚拟。我们将在十月提供这次培训，然后在二月或三月再次提供。所以我们会在十月做一个20小时的课程。我知道现在我们的网站上写的是40小时，20小时是给任何人的，每个人都可以参加。春季的那次也将是另外20小时，再加上为任何瑜伽老师提供的额外20小时，让他们成为具有悲伤敏感度和创伤知情意识的从业者。社会工作者或LPC（持证专业咨询师）能获得继续教育学分（CE）吗？
If somebody's listening. Yes, we have. We have CEs through Spiritual Competency Academy through California. And most of us in the mental health world know that if California approves it, including clinical psychologists, APA approved that most states it's reciprocal. I know in Colorado it is. And they say that 90 that most states it's reciprocal i know in colorado it is and they say that 90 of states it's reciprocal well one of the things that is uh any of the ce providers that we talk to i'll give them this tip because it really does work um is that like especially social work boards but really all of them nursing and lpc boards too
如果有人在听的话。是的，我们有。我们通过加州的“精神能力学院”（Spiritual Competency Academy）提供CE学分。我们心理健康领域的大多数人都知道，如果加州批准了，包括临床心理学家，APA（美国心理学会）批准了，那么大多数州都是互认的。我知道在科罗拉多州是这样的。他们说90%的州是互认的。嗯，我们谈到的任何CE提供者，我会给他们这个建议，因为它确实有效……就是像社会工作委员会，但实际上所有的委员会，护理和LPC委员会也是……
there's this big focus on offering an ethics only requirement because there's ethical issues or people, they, anyway, they think that you can solve ethics issues through CEs. And so like our board, I think it's like up to like eight hours of ethics that I have to get, but there's no requirement other than ethics be somewhere in the title of the event, you know? So if a lot of people, if, if you, if you search for the ethics of grief or the ethics of working with grieving people or something, it's like, that makes that event now much more valuable to me because I don't have to drive eight hours and go to the seminar over here. I don't have to spend eight hours in Tuscaloosa at this one thing. I can get something
他们非常关注只提供伦理要求，因为存在伦理问题，或者人们……总之，他们认为可以通过CE来解决伦理问题。所以像我们的委员会，我想我必须获得大约8小时的伦理学分，但除了要求活动标题中包含“伦理”二字外，没有其他要求。所以如果很多人，如果你搜索“悲伤的伦理”或“与悲伤者工作的伦理”之类的东西，那会让那个活动对我来说更有价值，因为我不必开车八小时去参加那边的研讨会。我不必在塔斯卡卢萨花八小时参加那个活动。我可以得到一些……
that I actually want that also is, um, yeah. Cause I, you know, I'm just one of the most ethical people alive and i don't feel like i need any more training in that in that area yeah totally kidding yeah no that's helpful feedback for sure we're learning we're learning though the whole ce model so we're thrilled that we got it right especially the apa part because they are hard yeah that one's that one's not easy but once you get it though everyone gets reciprocity everywhere. So you pretty much can sell to almost every state with APA. So that's awesome.
我真正想要的，同时也是……是的。因为，你知道，我只是活着的最有道德的人之一，我不觉得我在那个领域还需要更多的培训。是的，完全是开玩笑。是的，不，这确实是有用的反馈。我们正在学习，我们正在学习整个CE模式。所以我们很高兴我们做对了，特别是APA的部分，因为他们很难搞。是的，那个确实不容易，但一旦你得到了它，每个人在各地都有互认。所以你几乎可以把课程卖给所有州，只要有APA认证。所以这太棒了。
Congratulations. Yes. Yeah, thank you. Well, I hope social workers and LPCs all take advantage of this. Sorry to cut you off. I just want to continue to remind people that you can Google this stuff. We'll link to all of it in the show notes. But you can find it and hopefully sign up for it. I'd love if the people at Taproot, I'd like to get one of your trainings in the future.
恭喜。是的。谢谢。好吧，我希望社会工作者和LPC都能利用这一点。抱歉打断你。我只是想继续提醒大家，你们可以谷歌搜索这些东西。我们会在节目说明中链接所有内容。但你可以找到它，并希望注册参加。如果Taproot的人能参加，我希望将来能举办你们的培训。
The next couple of months are pretty hairy for me. But, you know, it seems to be something that's growing and increasingly more needed. I would love for you to attend. That would be really fun. And obviously we have that virtual option, but we can definitely talk about offering something there at some point. But the good news is the beauty of one of the glimmers of COVID is it's opened up this world of being able to do it virtually too. And when you, can you say anything more about like the integrative nature of it, how somebody could be a provider that does Jungian therapy or
接下来的几个月对我来说相当忙碌。但是，你知道，这似乎是一件正在增长且越来越被需要的事情。我很乐意让你参加。那会很有趣。显然我们有虚拟选项，但我们绝对可以谈谈在某个时候在那里提供一些东西。但好消息是，新冠疫情带来的“闪光点”之一是，它开启了虚拟完成这一切的世界。当你……你能多说一点关于它的整合性质吗？一个人如何成为一名提供荣格疗法、或……
gestalt therapy or somatic experiencing or sensory motor and that, you know, they don't have, it's not like it's not something they can use because it isn't explicitly from those modalities. I mean, it seems like what you're doing is at the intersection of a lot of different things. So I just want to give people the opportunity to hear the relevance of it for them. Yeah, I think many, many, many, many different theories in psychology just don't touch on the body part of it. And so if we can get in touch with how we work with the body, that will help as a therapist, because many of us were trained how to do talk therapy, right? And then the other part is including somatic experiencing and different somatic type theories out there.
格式塔疗法、躯体体验疗法或感觉运动疗法的提供者，你知道，他们不必……这并不是说他们不能使用它，因为它不是明确来自那些流派。我的意思是，你所做的事情似乎处于许多不同事物的交汇点。所以我只是想让人们有机会听到它对他们的相关性。是的，我认为心理学中许多许多许多不同的理论根本没有触及身体的部分。所以如果我们能接触到我们如何与身体工作，那作为治疗师会有所帮助，因为我们大多数人受训的是如何进行谈话疗法，对吧？然后另一部分是包括躯体体验疗法和现有的不同躯体类型理论。
We are experts in grief. Right. And so we want to bring in that grief piece for people that already may know about body based work, but understand how the science of grief, how it works in our brains and our bodies in order to work towards integration and finding meaning and purpose. And it's important to say finding meaning and purpose. And it's important to say finding meaning and purpose, I never mean that things happen for a reason. Some people believe that from their background, their religious faith, but that's not what light stands for, because that's not true for everyone. It means how do I move forward as I've grown with this grief? What can I do with this now? And that part is really important, the caveat that I think is really important for people to say. Like I said, I have clients in there that in here in my
我们是悲伤方面的专家。所以我们想为那些可能已经了解基于身体的工作，但了解悲伤的科学、它如何在我们的大脑和身体中运作，以便致力于整合并寻找意义和目的的人们带来悲伤的部分。而且重要的是要说寻找意义和目的。重要的是要说寻找意义和目的，我从来不是指事情发生必有原因。有些人从他们的背景、宗教信仰中相信这一点，但这并不是“光”所代表的，因为那对每个人来说并不真实。它的意思是，随着我带着这份悲伤成长，我该如何前进？我现在能用它做什么？那部分非常重要，我认为人们必须说出这个警告，这非常重要。就像我说的，我有客户每天在我的……
office every day that say, I believe this happened for a reason. And that's okay, because that's part of their process. But that's not true for everybody. And that's not true for most every parent who's experienced the death of a child. And yeah, there's not a formula for it. Those are the, those are the, the trainings that I'm kind of suspicious of is where it's presented like, this is the right way that you treat this one thing for all people. Right. And I think the individual nature of what you, what you guys have put out there, what I seen um really kind of speaks to the thoughtfulness and the wisdom of it yeah absolutely absolutely do um do you see like or i'm you haven't done the training but do you in the training or in in your work do you kind of link greek back to larger kind of cultural and political forces. I mean, I think it was, I think it was like in 2016,
办公室里说：“我相信这件事发生是有原因的。”这没关系，因为那是他们过程的一部分。但这并不适用于所有人。这并不适用于大多数经历过丧子之痛的父母。是的，没有公式。那些是我有点怀疑的培训，就是那种呈现方式，好像“这是治疗这一件事的正确方法，适用于所有人”。没错。我认为你们所呈现出的个人性质，我所看到的，确实体现了它的深思熟虑和智慧。是的，绝对是。你是否……或者你还没有做过培训，但在培训中或在你的工作中，你是否将悲伤与更广泛的文化和政治力量联系起来？我的意思是，我想是在2016年，
everybody that I saw right left, it doesn't matter. They felt like they lost and they were really angry. And so the people who would come in would say, you know, if they were right leaning, well, everything's woke and it's communist and it's terrible and I should be able to fix all of it, but I can't. So there's no point. And then all the people who were left-leaning would say, you know, there's social justice and discrimination and legalized murder and all these awful things. And I should be able to fix all of it, but I can't. So there's no point. And kind of taking
我看到的每个人，无论左右，都没关系。他们觉得他们输了，他们非常愤怒。所以那些进来的人会说，你知道，如果他们是右倾的，嗯，“一切都是觉醒文化（woke），这是共产主义，太可怕了，我应该能解决所有这些问题，但我不能。所以没意义。”然后所有左倾的人会说，“你知道，有社会正义、歧视、合法谋杀和所有这些可怕的事情。我应该能解决所有这些问题，但我不能。所以没意义。”然后……
each person and saying like, okay, look, what you're saying is you should have all the power, but you don't. So you just are going to abdicate and have none of it. And I think that that is an adult. I think that that is basically a grief loop and that what you have to do is recognize like you don't get it. These problems go back to the bronze age. Go out there and find something meaningful to do that affects a small amount of people and help yourself accept this is what we get. We have the ability to connect a small group and what we're able to do. We never get to be the get. We have the ability to connect a small group and what we're able to do. We never get to be the Messiah.
对待每个人并说：“好吧，看，你所说的是你应该拥有所有的权力，但你没有。所以你只是要放弃，什么都不做。”我认为那是一个成年人。我认为那基本上是一个悲伤循环，你必须做的是认识到，你得不到它。这些问题可以追溯到青铜时代。走出去，找到一些有意义的事情去做，影响一小部分人，并帮助自己接受这就是我们所得到的。我们有能力连接一小群人，以及我们能做的事情。我们永远不会成为……我们有能力连接一小群人，以及我们能做的事情。我们永远不会成为弥赛亚。
We never get to be the center of it. You know, the hero myth is something that left alone leads to just this kind of inflation and ambivalence. So, and they all found something meaningful to do. You know, I didn't agree with all their politics or something, but that didn't have to, because what they went out and did was good and something I did agree with. You know, that didn't have to because what they went out and did was good and something I did agree with.
我们永远不会成为它的中心。你知道，英雄神话如果单独存在，只会导致这种膨胀和矛盾心理。所以，他们都找到了有意义的事情去做。你知道，我并不赞同他们所有的政治观点或什么，但这不必，因为他们走出去所做的事情是好的，是我赞同的事情。你知道，这不必，因为他们走出去所做的事情是好的，是我赞同的事情。
We didn't have to have complete parity. And I think connecting our political neuroses and our sort of cultural anxieties to grief is something that as a therapist for me has been really useful. Do you do that or see that? You may not agree with that. I'm just curious since I have a grief expert on. Oh, I mean, a hundred percent. Right. And I will say
我们不必完全一致。我认为将我们的政治神经症和我们的文化焦虑与悲伤联系起来，作为一名治疗师，对我来说非常有用。你这样做吗，或者看到这一点吗？你可能不同意这一点。我只是好奇，因为我有一位悲伤专家在场。哦，我的意思是，百分之百。没错。我会说……
just, I mean, in my community, probably people know that I being more of a hippie, I see a certain type of population, but that's not necessarily true. Cause I also work with a lot of kids from some of the private schools and they are really opposite in what they believe in their families believe than what I do. But we all have experienced this loss of feeling like our country is going in the direction that feels safe and at peace. Right. And so absolutely. And it's, and it's the understanding of that universal experience, right? Even though you, Joel, have experienced different things than I have, we know that we both have experienced loss, even if we were on opposite sides of, say, a political spectrum, right? And so, which I sense we're probably not because we're social workers, but you never know.
只是，我的意思是，在我的社区里，人们可能知道我更像个嬉皮士，我看到的是某种特定的人群，但这不一定正确。因为我也和很多私立学校的孩子一起工作，他们的信仰和他们家庭的信仰与我所做的真的相反。但我们都经历了这种失落感，觉得我们的国家正在走向一个感觉安全和平的道路。没错。所以绝对是。而且是对那种普遍经历的理解，对吧？即使你，乔尔，经历过与我不同的事情，我们知道我们都经历过失落，即使我们处于政治光谱的对立面，对吧？所以，我感觉我们可能不是，因为我们是社会工作者，但你永远不知道。
So I think it's important to know that, yes, and it's trying to find that connection with different people of saying, yeah, we know this. This is hard. This is hard. And that helps also decrease judgment, right? If we can find that we are connecting together, we can decrease some of our judgment. Well, that's beautiful. I really appreciate it. Is there anything that we don't quite get to or anything that you feel like is relevant or helpful for the show that you want to include
所以我认为重要的是要知道，是的，并且要尝试与不同的人找到那种联系，说：“是的，我们知道这一点。这很难。这很难。”这也助于减少评判，对吧？如果我们能发现我们正在相互联系，我们就能减少一些评判。嗯，那太美了。我真的很感激。有什么我们没谈到的，或者你觉得对节目相关或有帮助的，你想包括在内吗？
in your message to therapists about grief or your message to people that may be interested in some of your offerings and classes? I think I guess the biggest message that I'd like to really share is that we all experience loss, all of us. And there are tools that can help us integrate it and finding purpose, which thus means that there is hope. Well, that's beautiful. Thank you so much for coming on and for your time and then i my computer is a big all-in-one thing i can't pick up the webcam easily but i was going to show you this wall behind you has a lot of paintings from emile bistrom um of the talos transcendental art
在给治疗师关于悲伤的信息中，或者给那些可能对你的一些产品和课程感兴趣的人的信息中？我想，我猜我想分享的最大信息是，我们都经历过失落，我们所有人。有一些工具可以帮助我们整合它并找到目的，这意味着希望。嗯，那太美了。非常感谢你来参加，感谢你的时间。然后，我的电脑是一个很大的多合一设备，我不能轻易拿起摄像头，但我本来想给你看，你身后的这面墙上有埃米尔·比斯特罗姆（Emile Bistrom）的很多画作，来自陶斯超验艺术……
movement um that i've got because they kind of recommend one of them reminds me of kind of a yungi and alchemical thing and the other one reminds me of brain spotting. And then there's tapestry. That's beautiful. Yeah. I love that. Yeah. So I really appreciate it.
运动，我之所以有这些，是因为它们有点……其中一幅让我想起了一种荣格的炼金术，另一幅让我想起了脑点疗法。然后还有挂毯。那太美了。是的，我喜欢那个。是的。所以我真的很感激。
We'll link to all of these things in the show notes. If you're in the Alabama area, whether or not you want to try and receive services through Taproot, there is a grief charity that we work with, Be Brave for Isla. So anyone that's had a recent death of a child can contact Be Brave for Isla, and they're able to get some sessions reimbursed locally if there's a person who hears this. And then we have the ability to submit those forms internally if you come here, but it isn't just something that we administer. It's a good thing. And then, so we'll link to that. And then we'll link to everything that Amy talked about, different parts of her site with some events, and that will be hitting YouTube and the podcast library pretty soon. So thank you so much. And hopefully we will be talking again as this grows and your offerings change. We'll be back here in, you know, your two years. So thank you so much.
我们会在节目说明中链接所有这些东西。如果你在阿拉巴马地区，无论你是否想尝试通过Taproot接受服务，我们合作的一家悲伤慈善机构是“为艾拉勇敢”（Be Brave for Isla）。所以任何最近经历丧子之痛的人都可以联系“为艾拉勇敢”，如果有人听到这个，他们可以在当地获得一些报销的疗程。然后我们有能力在内部提交这些表格，如果你来这里的话，但这不仅仅是我们管理的事情。这是一件好事。然后，我们会链接到那个。然后我们会链接到艾米谈到的所有内容，她网站的不同部分以及一些活动，这些很快就会出现在YouTube和播客库中。所以非常感谢。希望随着它的增长和你的产品变化，我们能再次交谈。我们会在你两年后回到这里。所以非常感谢。
Our virtual classes are good for anyone, including all of your clients there. And we'll be building that platform in the next month. Well, that's wonderful. That's great to know. Yeah. We're just licensed here, so we can't see anybody outside of Alabama. So it's always great when we have a guest that can see people that are outside of this area. So I'll link to all of that, and thank you so much. Hey, guys. I wanted to go ahead and give you that information again on the podcast. It'll still be in the show notes, but if you want to go to light, L-I-G-H-T-M-V-M-T.com.
我们的虚拟课程对任何人都有好处，包括你们那里的所有客户。我们将在下个月建立那个平台。嗯，那太棒了。很高兴知道这一点。是的。我们只是在这里有执照，所以我们不能看阿拉巴马州以外的任何人。所以当我们有一位能看到该地区以外的人的嘉宾时，总是很棒。所以我会在所有这些内容中添加链接，非常感谢。嘿，伙计们。我想在播客上再次给你们提供这些信息。它仍然会在节目说明中，但如果你想去 light, L-I-G-H-T-M-V-M-T.com。
Again, that's L-I-G-H-T-M-V-M-T.com. Again, that's L-I-G-H-T-M-V-M-T.com. That is the website where you can find all of the other work that Amy's done. And the theme music for this episode is Jeffrey Seiler from his new album, Definitely, used with permission. Check it out. We have an interview with him. And you can also check out his album anywhere albums are sold. Wounded in similar ways
再说一遍，是 L-I-G-H-T-M-V-M-T.com。再说一遍，是 L-I-G-H-T-M-V-M-T.com。那是你可以找到艾米所做的所有其他工作的网站。本集的主题音乐来自杰弗里·塞勒（Jeffrey Seiler）的新专辑《Definitely》，经许可使用。去看看吧。我们对他有一个采访。你也可以在任何销售专辑的地方查看他的专辑。以相似的方式受伤。
Wounded in similar ways It sounds like something that a hippie would say But the truth is we're wounded In similar ways Oh Oh There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以相似的方式受伤。这听起来像是嬉皮士会说的话。但事实是，我们以相似的方式受伤。哦。哦。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。